I flew after jail the other day I flew
on the flight afterward and I had
[__] a bag I new an F was coming with
I had a little bag of reefer in my
[__] no you didn't yes I do this is a
conspiracy thing this is just to show
you how hard the airport people are
working with their [__] x-ray machine
now I had it in the baggie and I put
under my left nut no okay we're not
telling the story that's yes for freedom
of speech I'll call Obama right now
[__] this is wheel corruption
I'm I got freedom this is out of control
no this is not you're out of order
little EST is out of order this whole
[__] joints out of he is worse hold
on he is worse than thano much worse
than don't bring I love him but don't
bring this monster in here it's like a
it's like a it's like a crazy Fred
Flintstone want honesty I'm giving you
honesty I'm so your viewers know Hony
and your people know hon I don't want
okay we looking for the truth on this
show this is about the truth I I got a
point I got there and I had baggy
clothes on and I had a belt on they said
because you have baggy clothes on they
didn't know I lost pounds they said
we're going to put you to the X-ray
machine I'm standing there sweating
bullets
with this baggie under my [__] the
left nut's bigger than the right nut cuz
I'm a righty people don't know that I
thought I had cancer for a couple weeks
you know the opposite hand is always in
the control room listen to me so I'm
standing with my legs open with this
weed stinking you're like rney danger
listen stop watching [__] Rodney I
had this weave and we're stinking up a
storm not to mention my balls I'm
sweating now cuz I'm going to go to jail
tonight and all the guy goes he's clear
and he shook my hand I'm like my tax
payers are hard at work it was his lady
in my block that was a mil M before the
mil this 1979 nobody knew what a mil
show she had big tits and she'd always
wear uh uh what what do you call those
things in the 70s that no no no the oh
fishnet no no they wore you just pulled
it over your chest a corset no I don't
know you pulled it over your chest in
the ' 70s and you could just pull it
down and show your tits out and it just
covered oh a tube top tube top oh the
tube top whatever the [__] when you had
big tits yeah you would just them in the
shirt you just pull the tube top down
then you could suck those titties she
had two dogs that had that were blind
two French poodles that were blind she
have to cross them across the street and
they [__] in the park when we playing
basketball and she'd have little hot
pants how old little flipflop if I was
14 15 she was 39 wow 40 and every time
she was over there walking the dog I let
the ball go down the hill just so I
could walk by her look at that ass she
was mint MH titties everything was mint
so I and but a husband this is how hot
she was whenever she walked the dog the
husband would go on the balcony to watch
to make sure none of us attacked her cuz
he knew we were a bunch of Bandidos we
would have picked her up he knew right
what's that movie the [__] Outlaw
Josie Wales when they find the blonde
behind the [__] thing and they pull
her by her legs that's us when we were
133 we were looking to [__] somebody we
just didn't know who the [__] you know
what I'm saying I ran with crew that was
looking to [__] we were just looking for
the right way Like Straw Dogs but nobody
knew remember that movie Jesus all those
[__] guys hanging out on the roof we
were ready to go but nobody knew I was
in love with Fay with Fay that was her
name Fay and I was going to take her
down and she had two daughters one
daughter I was friends with the other
daughter dated and ended up marrying my
Goomba really tight friend of mine so
after we we listened to LED zpp too we
ate a bunch we did some angel dust and
we drank some beers and everybody we're
going to a party how did she dress was
she always hot always showed that short
shorts always short short shorts always
it could be [__] 10 below and she'd
have a [__] hot P so she knew what
she was doing oh yeah she her nipples
would always be hard in the winter oh my
God face was gorgeous so one night I
said tonight's tonight I'm taking that
[__] down it been about 2 years at
night when she would walked the dog at
11 the husband was older than her like
her husband was like 60 she was in for
the progr yeah oh she was there for the
for the ride yeah she was that wasn't
the girl's father no so I I went I got
some of my mother's flowers and I went
and it by the bushes and waited for to
come down with the two French poodles
and when she put the when she was going
to bend over the to put the French
poodles down I was just going to tackle
her and then give her the flowers who
tackles you and gives you flowers I'm a
Class
Act did you give her the flowers I
walked up behind her as I saw I was
going to grab her she turned on she goes
Coco what a surprise I I brought these
for you I had my best cologne on I
brushed my teeth Listerine everything I
was ready to eat her from the inside out
and I had never even had sex with a
woman before and she's like what are
these for and I told her how I felt I
love you I want to run away with you
told her that oh everything I told her
everything I needed to tell I had tears
in my eyes I got emotional and she goes
that's so sweet and I go can I kiss you
and she told me that if she ever gets
divorced that she'd consider
me she just told cuz I'm such a jerk off
you know what I'm saying you're 15 14 I
was a young kid and then I go can I kiss
you and she goes absolutely and I kissed
her on the cheek and then I looked down
I just started staring at her [__] and
she goes what's the problem and I just
started getting red you know when you're
14 you get warned up you get red and R
and she goes what's the matter and I go
I just want to touch your thigh and she
goes okay and I touched like the bottom
of her thigh MH and I could just feel
blood coming out of my dick everything I
had came out of me I had to run home
like Steven cigal
remember how Steven used to run all
limped up like he was half a [__] and
above the wall that's how I [__] ran
home all [__] up my God I said nothing
to nobody and then about four years ago
me and my Goomba Bobby went out for
breakfast and I go I would tell you the
time I was going to [__] rape Fay and
he goes why why am I hearing about this
now right it was 1979 I was a young kid
I was in love with Fay he goes you know
fate lives with me now because yeah he's
married to the daughter oh my God
and I go how's she looking he
goes she's still on fire she's 78 years
old and you know what she walks around
the house all day telling me how horny
she is really he goes maybe I'm like
what are he [__] 70 something we
giggled we giggled and that was it and
about two weeks later I get a call one
afternoon it's Bobby and I answer the
phone I what's up Bobby he goes hold on
something he wants to talk to you he put
Fay on the phone she's like how you
doing sweetheart W you come visit me I'm
like ah oh my God but I still remember
when I was playing kickball with Lucy
snorebush and
she that's not a real name Joey that's
not a real name who had a [__] up car
[__] had a [__] up mug but she was
like 5'8 and eth grade and I broke into
a house one and ate her [__] one night
I just couldn't take it this [__] was
banging and after my mother died SN Bob
Bend was Lucy snor
Bush I climbed up a [__] ladder like
like old old Suz won't you cry for me I
climbed up the ladder opened up a door I
knew she was out drinking so she wasn't
going to say nothing I just jumped on
the bed ate her [__] and left like a
burglar the night her name was Lucy sow
and she was [__] her Grill was okay but
her body was banging from the time she
was like seven this [__] was banging I
was like eight I met her but she used to
have a she used to have a auss
a broke into her house I was
like I was walking down the hill to the
house I'm think about who [__] am I
going to eat tonight and I knew his
chick was out like she was out earlier
and whenever she drank she was kind of
loose dog I went right into her yard put
a ladder in climbed up the [__]
ladder opened the window she's like
who's there who's there don't even ask
he just [__] pulled the pants ate a
monkey and climb back out of like a
[__] vampire she she SE me like a
week later she's like that was amazing
that night [__] yeah [__] yeah my
windows unlocked a thief in the night
and [__] I didn't even bang the [__] I
just ate it and left really like a
doctor [__] yeah listen I was like 16 I
probably come in my pants already I'm
not ready and say like I had no dick
left after eat some after you break into
a chick's house and eat a snatch you
can't say that someone Joey knowah 's
done
that the only but I had basketball when
we were kid I know you're talking about
that you never tried to sneak into a
chick's house need a [__] on the quer
no not that part good not that part but
you know you add in plus factor in Joey
okay no I you know he was saying yeah
but never on a qu I said well that's
what Joey Diaz you got to factor that in
the quu was good to I was all horned up
and [__] but but with that that would
show that there's women out there
sitting in the house waiting for them to
be eaten out like she didn't even put up
a fight she knew me I was in the
neighborhood she Lucy SN cop
neighborhood she's Lucy SN Bush what the
[__] what the [__] going to call the
cops more you know mother I knew the
brother I knew the father I knew the
whole [__] family how she not get
tortured in school just for that oh we
tortured her you know we torture Lucy
snor Bush the whole time we used to call
her Lucy Bush you know what I'm
saying Lucy Bush [__] dog I'm F any
girl with a last name that's Bush what a
Luc SN Christ and she's on
Facebook she won't be my friend but
she's on Facebook she has taking my
friend request you know what I think the
therapist told her that was [__] up
what happened 20 years ago one night I
was staying at that hotel and I was
hungry one afternoon and I crossed the
street to the gas station cuz that's how
much money I had and I saw for help sign
and I asked the guy what are you looking
for and he goes I need to Mar pump gas
from 4 to 12 I go okay can when can I
start he goes tonight he goes what's
your name I'm
like Ryan
sickler he's like Ryan sickler okay I
see you at 4:00 so I come back and I
realize I'm by
myself so he trains me for the first
hour I went across the street and I'm
pumping all this gas and he told me goes
it's n light nighttime so drop every
time you got 500 in your pocket put an
envelope put what time sign this paper
workk and put a drop in
there I don't I didn't see the reason to
you know so every hour like he told me I
take like a dollar bill and drop it a
dollar bill drop it because for some
reason it was like computerized he goes
I'll find that in my house if you don't
drop so about [__] 2:00 I realized I
got about
$1,200 plus whatever in the register
plus the food plus he's got a box of
change under the [__] register so I
took
everything I took everything at 3:00
Hershey bars the whole [__] thing and
I just walked across roof 4 jumped over
the [__] Banister in the side of it
caruse a wizard by me doing 990 and I
went home the next morning I look up I
look out my hotel window cops are there
the whole thing people have been pumping
gas for free for 4
hours have have you ever heard this
story it's the story my god when Ralphie
first moved to a lot of people don't
know like when you move to an old
Hollywood neighborhood you'll see a
celebrity in that neighborhood and you
go why is that person here well because
they lived in that neighborhood before
they made it and now they're going to
visit their friends and that
neighborhood it was the chick from the
wrestler my cousin Vinnie oh Marissa to
Marissa to's sister lived on that block
so you would see her walk with her dogs
all the time and this is a shitty part
of Hollywood Guns and Roses had a garage
across the street that's where they
lived so it was by the Guitar Center
right there and there's a big garage be
behind where Matthew MCC uh where
[__] uh what Marissa to's sister
lives and that's where Matthew used to
have his cars when he was broke they're
broken down garages and he had like a a
Volkswagen you know those two door
Volkswagens with the trunk in the front
he had one of those in no not a beetle
the the rabbit the r like not the rabbit
the square one but the longer one it
doesn't matter anyway he had one of
those in his in his garage and he would
come back there and work on them I
didn't know this I didn't even know
there was garages back there but Ralphie
lived
on
Sher back in that neighborhood that
neighborhood was Josh Wolf on Vista
Ralphie was on
shider Nick depalo and Mitch Hedberg
were on Sierra Bonita and Doug Stan Hope
was on kerson wow this is a hell of a
[__] neighborh and we'd all play
tennis at 3:00 down by Gorky Park a
Russian Park on Fountain there bro on
they used to sell nickel bags at the
park back then every afternoon we make
Doug Stan we make [__] sunti and we'd
all meet there at gy Park that's what
Mitch Hedberg wrote the joke about I
can't I'll never be as good as my wall
playing tennis all that [__] I still
remember coming to my house with Mitch
smoking dope and him telling me about
thinking of moving to New York I don't
know if it's a good move and me going
bro there's nobody in New York like you
I don't belong in New York there's 20 of
me there but you there ain't nobody like
you in New York and he got to New York
and he blew up like a [__] wow
was a hell of a [__] neighborhood so
wait what happened with the uh Matthew
mc mc yeah so Matthew mccon was one of
the celebrities in that neighborhood and
one day I'm sitting upstairs with
Ralphie and he's like you see this
[__] out here I'm like who is it
he's like Matthew MCC Ralphie had a
screen on his window you could see out
but you couldn't see in and Ralphie
would sit there in the afternoon and go
Matthew
mccon you
sucked suck 15 20 minutes and after a
while Matthew MCC would throw his wrench
down and go who the [__] is saying that
up there [__] you you got the balls to
say it he Matthew MCC you
suck [__] you and then the next day
again and then he would start with
Matthew MCC you owe me 750 for The
Wedding Singer whatever that
[__] [__] you how many movies have you
done but he couldn't see us but we could
see him and it was in a torture chamber
for like 3 months every time he went
back there Matthew MCC
I'm not listening to you [__]
today leave me the [__] alone every day
we had a war with him raie had a war
with him hey you've never connected with
MCC about this no until one day I went
to Ralphy and MCC was sitting on his no
Ralphie went because MCC threatened him
how about I come up there and beat you
up ry's like Matthew MCC you suck it was
like a broken record cons Matthew MCC
you suck oh [__] Ralphie's a Texas boy
too
Houston friends yeah I go up there one
day he's on the couch sitting there
Smoking Buns I'm like what the [__] wait
they became homies they became like for
that day then Ralphie hit and he moved
and I don't know what happened to the
relationship wow [__] and I said Jesus
Christ I don't know if I'm going to [__]
myself a fart but let me just take a
chance good move and I blew this fart
Joe Rogan that was so bad right we were
on a bus and people started running you
know the school buses people started
running to the windows right to swing
down the bus windows but here's what it
gets better I fart it again and the
teachers were going oh my God he's
changing flavors but the
wor changing flavors but the worst thing
was the cheerleaders are crying that's
how bad it smells they was sitting in
front of the bus
going wait he's changing flavor you ever
have those loads like I I used to I used
to be on probation and there was a dude
that was like a GI Jo dude that failed
the police test but his assistant was a
goodlook woman like she was kind of cute
if I was 30 she was like 38 nobody
talked to her and Boulder because she
had like a wooden leg like her leg was
kind of like she had like that little
limp but you could tell the [__] had
game like she could suck a [__] I would
look in the eyes and I could tell this
[__] is deadly but nobody talks to her
because of a [__] wooden leg or
whatever the [__] she's got she got shot
in Vietnam I didn't know what happened
to her and she was very nice I forget
what her name was see I'd always flirt
with her but when I was doing and I was
in the probation I figured out how to
[__] with the piss test I'm
uncircumcised so I would take like
[__] pool cleaner and put it on my
dick and then pull the skin over it and
put like a tab over like a bread tab
like a like a [__] rubber band and
then when I would go pee the guy would
watch me and I would take my the thing
out and just pee and then pull the skin
back and all the pool cleaner would go
into the [__] thing and then I would
zap the machine they would always say to
me this [__] is up to something
so he asked her he goes maybe you could
see what the [__] he's doing so I would
I I I knew and I would call and I'll be
there at 4 cuz they would call you and
then you had to call a machine that
would tell you what color was up mhm and
if the color came up that let's say your
color was maroon and they go today's
colors are green maroon and black you
have to call in and tell them what time
you're coming in
you head till 5:00 but you had to make
an appointment then she tell you no no
if he answered that means he was going
to watch you while you're pissed but
with me they had mirrors around me they
couldn't figure out what I was doing so
they sent her in so before I would go in
I'd [__] do a half a jerk in the car
and get my dick nice and big yeah and
then I'd sprinkle it the [__] uh Pool
Cleaner the pool cleaner or the [__]
doesn't sting your dick the P did I I
got scars I got little holes into my
dick and Drano I would LED it up I would
[__] put it under my dick and then
pull the skin back and it would fall
into the piss test and zap it but before
I would piss I would take the hammer out
and show it to her like what do you
think what do you think there's
something nice and she would look at it
and look around the room and not like I
knew I I was going to end up sleeping
with her or swapping Spit with cuz I
flirt with her nobody talked to the
woman because she had a [__] up leg so
I'm off probation I'm delivering Chinese
food and I'm slinging Coke at the same
time at the Chinese restaurant so I
would have to would have you call the
Chinese restaurant and say can I talk to
Joey yeah would say oh you want egg drop
soup whatever the cocaine would be
hidden under the egg drop soup so if I
got in trouble the Chinese people got in
trouble I didn't put it in the bag this
was when I was out already out of
prison one night I knocked on the door
who answers the door it's her and she
goes oh my God it's so great to see you
how have you been I go it's great to see
you man I gave her a hug and I put the
Chinese down and she goes what are you
doing with your life I I'm getting
divorc divorced but I got to stand up
calmly and I'm trying to deliver food to
make a living and she's like oh that's
so sweet you you and her broke up oh you
must need a hug and as I started hugging
we started Swap and spit and I touched a
little monkey and I could feel nobody
had even touched a monkey in like 10
years steam started coming up and I
started fingering that [__] like
a Savage and SWA and spit with her and
my hand was nice and wet and I'm
fingering that I got a pinky surrounding
her [__] and I'm working and finally
I put it down slowly and I pop her pants
I take her tit out she's got one big
[__] TT I'm suck of a [__] I'm I'm
[__] I'm making out with it I'm
fingering at the same time so while I'm
fingering it I take a pants down but I
go I don't want to see what the other
leg is so I took the leg off of the good
leg and I left the [__] bad leg cing
cuz I don't want to know what it is if
she's got like a pole under there one of
those [__] up
feet I want to see so I picked up a
[__] legs and I started eating a
[__] and the [__] [__] was huge I'm
sucking on it like a p like a piece of
bubble I look up at her and she's like
this Christine like with her mouth open
I go now is the time to put the helmet
in that [__] mouth so I switched up I
started two finger Ling her and I went
around her and I put that [__] hammer
in her mouth and she didn't know what to
do she's like and I was and at that time
and at that time I was trying to [__]
lift weights and [__] so I wasn't
jerking off cuz somebody told me not to
jerk off that your protein I was
[__] I'm [__] yeah and when I
came in the mouth it was one of those
loads Christine that don't stop you have
one of those things and you're sucking
it you're sucking it with your eyes
closed and then after a minute you open
it up cuz you're like what is this going
to stop and I could look at us
swallowing it and it was endless it was
[__] endless it was just a load of De
it was like a month and a half and not
coming there was valum in there and next
and [__] nice seeing you Joey thanks
for stopping by I shot a load in the
mouth and when I took my dick out she
went it was like she drag a g on the
Mountain Dew she looked at me she
started getting a little
dizzy oh my I was selling volume at the
time I was taking like 100 milligram of
volume a night well I shot in her mouth
to put her in a trance she was glassy
eyed she gave me a $3 tip and I left and
I never saw her again she must have ate
that Chinese from and slept for a week
oh my god oh you got any dates coming up
you
want you you can still you can still
feel what that nut felt like I bet right
oh it was like a it was like a 3 minute
nut wait a minute you didn't even bang
her you put it in her Vine no that's the
pussed was tremendous oh okay I L her
ass I blacked out at some point I didn't
listen closely once I shove my tongue in
your ass you black out it's like it's
like you're 14 and your uncle's
molesting you you
know you just black out and let happen
what's going to happen
[Laughter]
[Music]
anyway
small charts in a big
world full of
people up with Hunger I have to have
that coffee first then I got to wait 10
minutes then I got to hit the tutut and
then once I hit the tutut about an hour
later when I smell bacon before I go on
the shower then I go you know what I
could eat some at one point do you [__]
out the window uh did you ever do that
for Old Time sake no about 8 years ago I
started [__] in tubs cuz I just
couldn't take it no more while I shut up
while I was taking a shower why get out
let me tell you something for some
reason or another listen to me jze for
some reason or another for about two
years every I hate going I like [__]
before I go in the shower but I like
[__] before I go in the shower I
don't want to take a shower and then
walk around with a dirty ass all day
because it leaks you got to B you got to
stop every hour and clean it and then it
gets hot out so I don't like I like
taking a [__] before I go in the shower
but there's some days the system don't
work according to your [__] [__]
schedule so you wash and then you come
out some days I was taking a shower as
soon as the water would hit my back and
have to take a [__] and that's a worst
let me tell you something when you got
to dry off take a [__] and and it's and
it and it makes you have to go to the
bathroom as soon as the water hits you
so sometimes you do sit on a wet toilet
and it's a horrible feeling it's a worst
feeling it's a horrible feeling so for a
while there I was just saying [__] it
let me just [__] while I'm taking a
shower so you you and then would you
scoop it out un no I would either
unscrew that thing sometimes I pick it
up with my hand just throw it
right Joe stop that's how disgusting I
am sometimes I would just [__] in Vegas
sometimes I was eating pills and doing
blow and I would just sit in the thing
with my legs open like a Chinese guy you
know how they [__] in China but only
with water hitting my ball sack and my
[__] at the same time it's a party
and I would just [__] and watch the [__]
come out with all the particles and then
I get like the soap push it down a hole
like a yes I would I'm disgusting I I
got to admit to it right now anybody
who's ever taking a shower at Joey
Diaz's house I would do it in hotels I
would Jesus push it down the peanuts
would get stuck in the thing so the
drain couldn't go back down you don't
know I can't see
hotels I'm never staying in another
hotel you don't know what life is like
the papa they were Legit to
Quit but the Ali were the first people I
ever met ever
beside my godfather that ever spoke to
me about
sex and then I had this Puerto Rican
dude on my block Puerto Rican Nelson he
lived in the back he was a bartender in
the city he used to always ask me and he
wasn't a freak or nothing I always
thought that one point he would molest
me yeah and even till today I think deep
sometimes [__] Puerto Rican Nelson
never molest me cuz he used to always
have a Rob on and slippers and
[__]
that's how he walked around oh my God
Puerto Rican Nelson I love that you're
not sure if he did you feel like it's
maybe yeah like I think did he ever a
dope me like he pull a Cosby on me
because everything about him fits like
ano he was just a good dude yeah that we
used to go outside and help us fix our
bike and he was a Spanish dude and he
was just you know he had the sideburns
and the leather jacket and it was the
[__] early 7s and I moved to Jersey
and he would talk to a bunch of us and
one day he would take us in the back his
claim to fame with me was that I became
friends with him and I go over there and
he had a black friend uh that went over
to the rocker jalter and he brought
pictures back and then he would just
talk to me then one day he asked me
meet he had he had a couple you ever go
to somebody's house and you you go to
their house a lot and they're sober but
one day you catch in their [__]
Hamond yeah and we go over there and
it's like early in the morning like I
used to go over there every morning at
10 and wake him up and and and what's up
man what are we going to do today give
me an hour I'll go out there and play
stickball with you and he come out with
coffee and he red of
alcohol you know he was one of those
dudes in the summer you know no air
conditioning your just a dynamite dude
yeah and one day uh I knock on the door
and he answers with a towel around him
and he's sitting down like he's all
[__] up
like well Nelson you going to play
football he's like man not today you
know and all this [__] he goes come back
in like two hours so you know we in
those days you're punctual yeah like we
were there in two
hours he answered you guys again the
[__] curtains were still up he
invites Us in he's got a towel on you
know he turns the light on and there's
like a table filled with alcohol you
know and like oh yeah how old were you
at this point 12 12 and I can't remember
remember who the [__] I walked in there
with like it was like six of us in the
neighborhood that liked Nelson but two
of us actually interacted a little
closer with Nelson yeah I was Spanish so
I understood Nelson's world I knew
Puerto Rican people but I can't believe
who el else was the other guy that
mingled with Nelson so we had woken
Nelson up he goes come in come in we s
this couch you guys want a soda he gives
us a soda he puts the TV on you can see
he's still [__] up my the night before
he's got the towel on and he's like so
you guys get late and we don't know what
the [__] he's talking about like nobody
ever spoke to me like that I had uncles
that would ask me anybody suck your dick
yet yeah are you piss and sweet yet that
type of [__] but
this oh yeah yeah when you're
Spanish you know what I'm saying great
yeah it's it's a great
line but Nelson was basically the first
person to ever like I ain't known about
sex but Nelson was the first person ever
that said it could be yours you know I'm
like like what do you mean you never had
sex I got a girl right now she'll come
over and clean your pipe like we're both
like [__] [__] in our
pants yeah you come up with like $10 or
something like nah no no so that was it
he never talked about it again and then
when they were sitting there like a
month just saw this guy a guy in a
[__] towel has neighborhood boys over
at offers get the
aore and he's drunk because he's
outraged with the heaven had sex at 14
or
12 so he was cool as [__] he used to
play basketball with us and [__] so one
day I go over there with this kid and he
starts telling us what's his name again
Puerto Rican Nelsa we
go
is it be capitalized no Puerto Rican
Nelson was cool as [__] because he used
to bring us weed from the city and he
would actually give us seven joints for
$5 wow he really took care of us it
wasn't like he was a bad guy which to me
meant the world because a lot of people
could bring you weed over in those days
but they say I take a joint off the top
he was like I got to go over there
anyway don't worry about it the guy
gives me a better deal so I always liked
him because of that so one day we're
there and a CH and a girl's there a girl
comes out of his bedroom me and my buddy
like wow look at Puerto Rican now son
with a bro she sits on his lap and [__]
and he's like yeah this is my girl and
he's feeling her up and he's making out
in front of
her feeling he and
[__] and me and my buddy are frozen like
we're just I could feel I can feel I
can't remember who the [__] it was so w
how old was this guy this guy had to be
28 and the bro was like 21 but he was he
was one of those he had to be 26 maybe
he he was from somewhere else and he
lived there this before the computer and
before neighborhood watch and before and
and no one was freaked up by a pack of
12y olds hang out with them no because
in those days a lot of parents came out
and play with kids and
you see it's different I would never be
able to play with a random kid my
neighbor so everybody knew him for the
neighborhood and in those days we wanted
to go into mky Waters yeah and he was
kind of opening the door not really to
be honest with you it took a long time
it's not like he lurked us into his
house and said do you guys want to have
sex this is after we knew him for a year
right we we go back there all the time
to get water after a basketball game we
knew him you know but now he knew we
were growing up and he knew what our
needs were I look at it now like he was
he was just trying to but we couldn't
handle it yeah so one day we're sitting
back there we had a basketball game and
he's like hey man what' you think of
that [__] broad the other day me and
my bud like oh she was banging he goes
I'll tell you what he goes tell tell
these guys how hot she was and me and my
Bud's like yeah she was hot he's like oh
when can we see her he goes listen I
tell you what I'm going to do he goes
listen I'm going to [__] her tonight in
the living room and I'll leave the
window open you guys can come by and
[Laughter]
listen
that was his thing for like a dollar a
piece that was his fetish got into boys
listening to him [__] we got there he
was [__] the [__] out her doggy style
we all ran away we were like
mortified we got there 10 minutes before
he started [__] it we like did not
even in there all a sudden you heard oh
he's like yeah that s sucking
we tried to
look there must have been eight of us
trying to look at that window we just
heard them [__] [__] and I heard
meat like that's the first time I heard
balls and we ran out of that dog and the
next day he
like the next day he's like did you guys
come
by oh my
God that's the weirdest [__]
neighborhood guy I've ever heard
oh my God holy [__] that guy's great